hi everyone
i'm michael baldwin i lead financial
services product management for google
cloud
with me today is my colleague tom shane
also a financial services product
manager
thanks for joining us tom and i both
spend our days thinking about how we can
help financial institutions transform
their businesses with artificial
intelligence and machine learning
today we'll be sharing with you an
overview of some of the major areas
where we see this transformation
happening
and how google cloud can help we know
that business transformation is top of
mind for many of our financial services
customers
however these are challenging times with
financial services institutions
navigating the pandemic
interest rates are an all-time low
customer expectations are changing with
the shift to digital
for example digital banking has
increased from 63
in 2019 to 72 percent today
regulatory requirements of are evolving
and compliance costs are increasing
also the financial services industry as
a whole is facing new
and creative types of fraud for example
the dollar value of attempted fraudulent
transactions grew 35
in april year over year and finally with
the move to digital
disruption is accelerating for instance
the pandemic drove a 72
increase in the use of fintech apps in
europe
today we'll cover three areas where we
see ai helping to unlock business
transformation in financial services
first ai can help reimagine the customer
experience
to deliver things such as personalized
digital banking
contact centers with ai-powered virtual
agents and smoother custer
customer experiences for traditionally
paper intensive processes like lending
second financial institutions are
looking for ways to use data and
analytics to transform how they detect
and manage risk
and finally financial institutions ask
us for a best-in-class ai platform
that is flexible secure and compliant
that empowers them to build their own
ai-powered solutions to solve their most
critical business problems
as we talk about through examples of ai
powered transformation and financial
services
you'll see that ai isn't a science
experiment it's being used to solve
real-world problems
across banking capital markets insurance
and payments the key thing for us is
working with our customer
customers to identify their top business
problems
then figuring out how ai can be most
helpful for them
in solving for their key needs and
ultimately
our goal is to make it as easy as
possible to deploy these solutions
in real-world end-to-end workflows
deloitte recently surveyed over 2 700
global i.t
and line of business executives to
obtain a global view
of how organizations are adopting
benefiting from
and managing ai technologies and as you
can see from this recent deloitte survey
shown here on the slide 81 of customers
are reporting payback
on their ai in less than two years when
ai is absorbed in this way
it can lead to true business
transformation
so first let's talk about how artificial
intelligence can help transform the
customer experience
customer experience is obviously a broad
area let's talk through a few examples
of what this can mean
many financial institutions today
struggle to get a single view of the
customer
sometimes known as customer 360.
with the continued shift from physical
branches to digital
financial institutions are looking for
new ways to deliver high quality
and helpful experiences across all of
their customer touch points
lighting up omni-channel operations
across web
mobile contact centers physical branches
and atms
when it comes to acquiring new customers
financial institutions want to onboard
in days
not weeks and are looking to use ai
powered intelligence to help retain
those customers
finally as customer 360 becomes a
reality
will be able to enable ai powered
experiences to sell the right product
to the right customer at the right time
and also drive other personalized
insights to help with customer retention
and new business acquisition
our contact center ai solution is one
example of how ai
is helping reimagine the customer
experience
first let me share a quick overview of
our of our contact center ai solution
the goal of contact center ai is to
deliver exceptional customer service
and increase operational efficiency
using artificial intelligence
it enables virtual agents to converse
naturally with customers
and expertly assist human agents on
complex cases
it does this through a set of underlying
powerful features
for example dialog flow which automates
basic chat and voice interactions
a feature called agent assist which
makes human agents more effective
and insights which unlocks insights
about call drivers and customer service
interactions customer support is
particularly relevant in financial
services
as financial institutions have seen a
thousand percent
increase in call volume since the onset
of the pandemic
customers are calling in with questions
like are branches still open
can i defer loan payments are you
waiving any fees right now
and of course security is paramount in
financial services
so our teams are hard at work making
sure that we have bank level security
built
into this product next
i want to share how we're working to
make lending more operationally
efficient and create smoother customer
experiences
our lending document ai alpha is built
on top of our document ai technology
document ai helps organizations
unlock insights from their mountains of
documents
using artificial intelligence by turning
unstructured data
into structured data which means you can
now actually understand and utilize it
with mortgage rates low there's a surge
in mortgage applications
this solution provides a bundle of
specialized models focused on specific
document types used in lending
and with this solution we're able to
work with lenders to quickly onboard
customers and speed up the processing of
paper-intensive mortgage applications
also when the us congress authorized the
paycheck protection program as part of
the pandemic relief package
we made the same technology available to
help with the processing of ppp loans
next let's talk about insurance dealing
with a car accident can be a major
headache for the automobile owner in a
time-consuming process for the insurer
we worked with usaa an insurer and a
google partner
mitchell to build ml models that analyze
images of cars that have been in
accidents and make damaged parts
estimates
this in turn can be converted into an
estimate of costs needed to repair the
car
saving appraiser's time and leading to a
smoother customer experience
now i'm going to hand things over to tom
shane my colleague and fellow product
manager for financial services
who will walk us through how ai is
driving business transformation and risk
management
and also we'll share an overview of how
our ai platform is being used by
developers
and data scientists inside financial
institutions to deliver on their top
business priorities
over to you tom thanks michael
when google cloud thinks about how we
can help apply
ai and ml to transform financial
services in the risk management space
we typically think about four key things
first
is mitigating risks across channels and
digital experiences
as michael said financial institutions
are increasingly looking to move to
a digital first posture in the
post-covet environment
that provides great benefits from a
customer experience perspective
but it does open up new vectors of risk
and potential fraud
for example rising scams in the retail
banking segment
second moving to holistic and contextual
analysis
by holistic we mean extracting signals
from traditional structured data sources
but also combining that
with insights from unstructured data to
form one holistic
or customer 360 view that allows
financial services organizations to
contextually analyze
customers and events and detect true
anomalies or risks that need to be
reviewed
from normal behavior for that customer
or event
third thinking about how to dynamically
and rapidly respond
to changing risk types for example
changing macroeconomic
and market conditions or new fraud types
in the postcovid world
and finally being able to offer that
worry-free and seamless customer
experience
customers want to know that the risk
management systems that are operating in
the background
are keeping their accounts and assets
safe but they don't want those systems
to inappropriately impact their customer
experience
for example a false positive alert on a
fraud transaction
next i want to talk about a customer
who's working to help
transform their risk management
processes
hsbc is working with google cloud to
leverage the latest in machine learning
to dynamically assess potential
financial crime risk
and holistically look at customers hsbc
is bringing their extensive knowledge
of combating financial crime which
combined with google's expertise in
developing ml solutions
is already leading to encouraging
results in this area
you may have heard from our ceo thomas
curion's keynote the google cloud is
focused on building up
digital transformation solutions powered
by google's ai
in risk management we're focused on
giving you a preview of two of those
solutions today
the first is annie money laundering or
aml and the second
is know your customer or kyc i want to
talk about some of the challenges and
opportunities in each of these areas
when our customers ask us about aml they
often talk about challenges around the
current rule-based system
in that sophisticated bad actors can
sometimes get around these systems
leading to potential
missed money laundering events and these
system often lead to
many false positives on the data side we
also hear challenges about poor data
quality
and the lack of that holistic or
customer 360 view
to inform their aml efforts and finally
we hear that all of these false
positives
are creating heavy amounts of manual
work which is taking away from
higher value opportunities in terms of
opportunities for innovation
google cloud can help extract insights
from data
and apply ai and ml technologies to
better detect and prevent
and identify those real money laundering
events and then help organizations
operate more efficiently by reducing
false positives
as well as providing more insights in
the alert review process
know your customer or kyc is another
area that financial institutions often
ask us about
we hear challenges such as manual
processes around
looking at documents and combining that
with other information
we hear how this sometimes impacts the
customer onboarding process
either delaying it or leading to
excessive outreach to customers to
collect information
and finally we hear about challenges of
integrating all this information
into banks overall systems we think
there's three key opportunities to help
improve this process
the first is helping in the automation
part by automation we mean
looking at all of the documents received
in the kyc process
and automatically extracting insights
entities and information from these
documents
and putting them into downstream
processes we also think there's an
opportunity to move
to a rapid and digital onboarding
process especially important in the
post-covet environment
and finally we think extracting insights
from these documents can help better
identify potential risk
sooner as well as inform financial
services organizations
overall customer 360 efforts
next i want to turn to the capital
market space and b and y melon
it was using machine learning to help
predict treasury settlement failures
the treasury market is one of the
largest and most liquid in the world
however one to two percent of
transactions fail every day
which equates to about 70 billion
dollars so bny melon is leveraging
google cloud
to develop end-to-end pipelines to
better predict when these settlements
might fail
this has allowed b y melon to get in
front of these potential failures
and out mitigate them before the daily
cutoff
outside of solutions in the customer
experience and risk management space
we also know financial institutions want
to build their own ai and ml models
for a range of different use cases and
business problems so at google cloud
we're focused on
building and deploying a flexible
platform to allow financial services
organizations to build out these models
and this is based on google's learnings
running large-scale ml systems
we believe that responsible ai equals
successful ai
when we at google think about
responsible ai we typically
think about four key pillars the first
is robustness
and that's making sure results stay
robust over time
the second is ensuring that these
systems are understandable
the third is considering the fairness
implications
of these systems and the fourth is
incorporating security by design to keep
both the data and the assets secure
throughout the entire model life cycle
in terms of robustness at google we've
found that transitioning to end-to-end
machine learning pipelines
greatly helps in this way we see that
an ml system is much more than just a
model it's about consistently
extracting and validating data ensuring
the data distributions don't shift
over time it's about applying the right
features
and the right model to the problem
training the model evaluating the
results
and ultimately deploying it to
production a common failure mode that we
often hear from our customers
is a great model that works well in
development
but can't transition to production or
doesn't replicate results
in production so we've introduced ai
platform pipelines which is coming soon
to help with this problem ai platform
pipelines is
integrated with other gcp native
services such as our data warehouse
bigquery
and our ai serverless training platform
we know that financial institutions are
also focused on making sure
ml systems are understandable we know
that this is key in financial services
for a couple key reasons
the first being that these systems often
underpin
high value business problems where the
results need to be robust
and they need to be understandable third
these systems often interact with humans
whether it's in a model governance
approval process or
in downstream processes such as an
analyst reviewing a fraud alert
and finally we know these models need to
meet regulatory obligations
so google has built our explainable ai
solution based on google's experience
understanding interpreting ml systems
this solution
provides feature attributions to say
which attributes or features are most
predictive of any given prediction
in this hypothetical example that you
see in the lower right hand corner you
can see that the amount
feature or attribute is most predictive
of this particular prediction
google is also very committed to ai and
ml fairness
we've released our ai principles which
govern applications
in which google applies its ai and ml
technology and we've also released
a fairness tool kit and i want to
highlight a couple components of it
first is the what if tool which allows
organizations to dynamically
dissect their data and results the
second
is fairness indicators which allows
organizations to provide
categories and then slice different
fairness performance metrics
by those categories to evaluate
differences across groups
and finally i want to talk about our
responsible ai practices which provide
guidelines to organizations implementing
these systems
next i want to talk about security and
how google cloud we're incorporating
this by design
in our ai platform and solutions we know
security is absolutely table stakes for
financial services organization
so we're focused on a couple areas the
first is preventing data exfiltration
with our vpc service controls and
ensuring no external internet access
the second is providing choice so
customers can use their own encryption
keys to encrypt and decrypt data
and customers can choose where data
processing happens
and where their data is stored in terms
of data residency
and finally always ensuring authorized
and appropriate access to that data
through fine grain identity and access
management controls
as well as our access transparency logs
finally i want to turn to a customer
who's using google cloud's ai and ml
infrastructure
two sigma has moved some of their deep
learning research to the cloud
in large part to leverage the latest in
aiml infrastructure
they're using google cloud's tensor
processing units or tpus
which are purpose-built chips by google
for machine learning training
and inference and you can see when two
sigma
moved their tensorflow workloads to tpus
they saw a boost in productivity which
allows them to spend less time
worrying about managing their ai and ml
systems and more time crafting results
in summary google cloud is focused on
providing
data-powered innovation in financial
services
we're building out ai-powered solutions
in customer experience
and risk management for financial
services organizations
and we're also focused on enabling a
digital platform
to allow financial services
organizations to build and deploy their
own ai and ml solutions
in a way that meets their requirements
we look forward to meeting you
and working with you to help transform
the future of financial services
if you're interested in learning more
please follow the url on this slide
thank you so much for taking time out of
your day and again we look forward to
working with you
you